and so this woman claims that she lost
her boyfriend to Red Pill content let's
pull it up so my boyfriend turned red
pill and at this point we haven't spoke
for about a month and I can't cope with
the fact that someone who I saw is so
compassionate and thoughtful and
intelligent so caring and open-minded
just completely did a 180 they were just
self supportive and caring and and even
when I would have my self- sabotaging
episodes they still loved me I feel like
red pill men stole my future husband
from me because I really really thought
this was the person and even after
talking about this I'm like physically
shaking because it was just so bad